here's a win-win situation for you watch
my review then go see the movie two
positives win-win stars Paul Giamatti
Amy Adams crap I didn't look up to
people's names okay Bobby Cannavale
Jeffrey Tambor and Alec Schaefer it's
about a married couple Paul Giamatti and
Amy Ryan and they have some kids and
they're just financially pretty much
hitting the bottom of the barrel he's a
lawyer and his practice is failing
financially he's having a health
problems based on stress Paul Giamatti
is also a wrestling coach and he has a
little team that's pretty much failing
also until he meets a kid played by Alex
Shaffer who's basically around away from
home and learns that he is an incredibly
good wrestler
so they strike up a good friendship
together Kyle starts to live with him at
his house and they start to do really
well in the wrestling matches obviously
this isn't his son and there's a lot of
family problems with this kid and
basically since they start to care for
each other so much it becomes a really
hard thing to be able to deal with
everyone's problems in it and they all
kind of come to the fore this is a
terrific comedy really I mean this is
the funniest film I've seen all year on
Monday I saw Arthur on Tuesday I saw
your highness and today I saw win-win
and it just blows those movies out of
the water and those films are like
little ants that are like smushed into
the dirt and they're all disgusting and
nasty and and everything this
movie is hilarious I was laughing out
loud many times and the audience I saw
it with was cracking up and actually
applauding at times because of some of
the great lines and really well-written
humor performances in this movie are
first-rate absolutely fantastic Paul
Giamatti is so good in this film if this
movie came out in December I would
probably say that Paul Giamatti would be
for an Oscar but it's coming out now and
as we know the Academy's memories in a
fairly short term Amy Ryan is great as
the mother the newcomer Alex Shaffer who
plays the boy I thought he did an
excellent job now you can look at his
performance and you can say wow that is
an awful performance because he just he
spends most of the movie very monotone
very quiet a lot of dislike uh-huh but
that's exactly how a kid dealing with
these type of problems that he's dealing
with act he would act withdrawn socially
and he would act quiet and he would be
awkward
a lot of times it's really welcome he
definitely nailed that that's the way
kids act when they're like that Jeffrey
Tambor plays the assistant coach he is
hilarious in this film oh my word he's
so funny and his best friend Bobby
Cannavale I'm not trying to say his name
is also very very funny I can't stress
how funny this movie was I was cracking
up so often that's just part of it the
reason it is so funny and the reason the
comedy works so well is because these
characters are so real they're written
so well and they're the performances are
so fantastic that you just really really
care about these characters and it's not
over-the-top humor me it's the kind of
stuff like in Seinfeld where you know
all the jokes were fairly realistic it's
like it's just the everyday kind of
stuff that happens to you that is funny
sometimes and it's hilarious to watch
it's also very touching and there's a
lot of heart in this film it's directed
by the person who directed the visitor
Richard Jenkins was great in that movie
that was a good film this is by far
considerably better though it's
hilarious the performances are excellent
it's directed well the script is
fantastic
wrestling scenes are also very exciting
I was really into what's happening
because once again I cannot stress the
reason I cared about what was happening
is because I cared about the people who
were involved with these situations and
that is how you make a good movie
win-win is one of the best movies I've
seen so far this year I'm going to give
it four out of four stars definitely
when it comes to your theater check it
out